je sais que quand je viens ici, je ressens Michael
et tu sais que je sais qu'il est ici avec
moi, donc je suis reconnaissant
et honoré de pouvoir encore faire ce travail
et d'être toujours là pour l'honorer
aussi longtemps que je vivrai, alors c'est quoi
quelle fierté de pouvoir faire
[Musique]
michael mon mari j'ai perdu michael
patrick eichen que j'ai perdu
tragiquement
le 9 11 que j'ai rencontré le 9 11 1999
et béni de l'avoir pendant deux ans
merci michael je sais que tu es
me parler maintenant c'est si précieux il est il est
juste ici donc c'est là que
je sais qu'il était pour la dernière fois c'est là qu'il est à la
maison
[Musique]
je suis ici pour célébrer ce qui aurait
été le 57e anniversaire de michael
je suis si heureux d'avoir des amis  et sa
famille ici en train de boire son merlot préféré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi